hi it's Brianna from free code camp
today we're going to be talking about
data size the smallest size of data you
can possibly have is called a bit now
that is I wrote a 1 here that's an
example of a bit it can really either
only be a 1 or a 0
it really goes back to that binary that
we were talking about 1 being on 0
meaning off it can either be a 1 or 0
that's a bit bigger than that we've got
a nibble which is 4 bits it's not very
commonly used but it's adorable
um bigger than that we've got a bite now
this is common referring something in a
byte it is 8 bits put together now a lot
of binary things are expressed with 8
bits like letters and symbols and what
most numbers really can be expressed
that way until you get to really big
ones so our most basic data sizes we've
got a bit and a byte but as you can
guess it gets much bigger than that all
right so after we get past the regular
small bit and the first little byte
which is 8 bits we get bigger really
fast the next step up is a kilobyte
which is 1,024 bytes which times 8 is a
whole lot more bits after the kilobyte
we've got megabyte which is 1,024 ^ 2
which is the same thing as 1,048,576
bytes so since we're growing
exponentially that is a big big increase
after megabyte we've got gigabyte also
known as a GB which is 1,024 ^ 3 then TB
terabyte 1024 to the power 4 and PD not
peanut butter it is head of it-- 1024 to
the power of 5 just to give you an idea
of how big this number is if you can't
see it I almost ran out of room writing
this on my whiteboard these are some
pretty big numbers we're dealing with
here
you probably recognize megabyte gigabyte
terabyte from regular storage that
you've dealt with before on your iPad
your iPod your computer or anything like
that all right just a quick review bit
tiny little either 1 or 0 byte 8 bits
kilobyte 1012
me four bytes after that everything is
an exponent off of 1024 going from
kilobyte to megabyte to gigabyte
terabyte all the way up to a petabyte